c'est ici à la Commanderie des Templiers
à é encour que le 22 juillet prochain
sera proposée une retransmission sur
écran géant de l'opéra Carmen Laurent
masori bonjour vous êtes le maire
adjoint à la Culture ici à éencour
comment va s'organiser cette
représentation sur ce site on attend
plus de 250 personnes un écran géant va
être mis en place la partie sonorisation
a été également étudiée puisqueune des
problématiques bien entendu pour un
opéra surtout un opéra de Carmen et bien
c'est d'avoir un son qui soit parfait
donc les travaux nécessaires ont été
réalisés en collaboration je tiens le
préciser avec l'Opéra de Paris he qui
est vraiment notre partenaire majeur
dans cette réalisation et nous aurons le
plaisir vendredi soir à 20h30 de
recevoir j'espère toute la population d'
lancours qui pourra rentrer j'en profite
pour le dire inscrivez-vous dès
maintenant en appelant l'hôtel de ville
parce que les places bien entendu sont
limitées et donc pourront assister à
cette représentation qui est la
retransmission d'une captation qui a
lieu à l'Opéra de Paris avec les
chanteurs de l'Opéra le cœur et
l'Orchestre de
l'Opéra enfant de poème il n'a jamais
jamais conu de loi si tu ne m'aimes pas
je
t'aime si je t'aime prends garde dans
toi ça permet de montrer ce qu'elle a
commandé des Templiers mais également
mettre en résonance le lieu avec l'art
lyrique et de porter au plus grand
nombre un art lyrique qui soit
accessible à tous et quel meilleur opéra
que celui de Carmen pour pouvoir
commencer à aborder l'opéra en de
manière générale ça préfigure un peu de
la de la programmation de la politique
culturelle sur la commune en tout cas
pour la nouvelle saison alors oui je
l'espère on y travaille encore on pourra
vraiment faire les annonces au mois de
septembre parce qu'il y a bien entendu
des problématiques de réservation entre
autres avec la partie opérative
c'est-à-dire les troupes c'està-dire les
réisations v mettre en place mais bien
sûr toujours une problématique
budgétaire sur lequel on travaille d'
rchepied et j'espère évidemment que ça
préfigure une une de nos orientations
l'idée étant d'apporter la culture au
plus grand nombre et de permettre au
plus grand monde de se mettre en contact
avec la culture sans avoir toutes ces
barrières psychologiques ou de principe
la culture c'est pas pour moi bien non
la culture c'est pour tout le monde et
un dernier mot peut-être concernant
cette opéra aussi pour donner au vie en
gens tout le monde connaît he plus ou
moins Carmen tout de même mais s'il y
avait une chose à dire pour les faire
venir bien je dirais que l'opéra de
Carmen bien entendu a une chanson très
très connue qui c'est si tu ne m'aimes
pas je t'aime mais donc comme on aime
tous les an cour toi venez nombreux puis
surtout la mise en scène qui est
absolument extraordinaire puisqu'elle
est elle est manière volontaire très
moderne elle s'inscrit dans le temps
présent et en même temps elle garde bien
entendu toute la tradition du poème de
prosperère mérimé que biset a su mettre
en musique à partir des livres
exceptionnels donc c'est un grand moment
c'est un moment de plaisir l'opéra de
Carmen est probablement un des opéras
les plus accessibles pour tous donc
surtout ne le ratez pas venez très
nombreux merci l masori ce sera donc ici
à hencour pour voir cette retransmission
et si vous souhaitez découvrir Carmen en
vrai cette fois-ci et à l'Opéra ce sera
en 2017 il faudra attendre le mois de
mars à l'Opéra de Paris